one more drink one more
drink you know in the morning
for sure we gonna stink one more
round one more round
it's
this is what we do catch up for a few
we'll riff and talk some [ __ ] and then
we'll sleep till two
[Music]
yo we're here baby good to see ya
good to see you man it's been a minute i
got a uh what's the word confess
last week i was so [ __ ] hungover i i
felt like i
i slacked off i didn't bring the heat so
tonight i did i snorted some adderall i
did some uh emergency i'm ready oh dude
i mean
i'm so glad you said that because i
might be slack in this episode man i
and first off i didn't notice you
slacking you you're always hilarious on
this but i was
uh i was [ __ ] i'm dying right now
i am i did like a pinch of vodka in this
giant
soda just cause like i don't want to be
a douche yeah
like god damn dude i'm yeah yeah i could
see it you got the you got the pail
going
by the way i love booze in a kid's cup
that's the ultimate sadness
you might as well go sippy at that point
what's a sippy cup
i do realize i got to step it up with
like wine glasses and martini glasses
but like
[ __ ] man there's something about there's
something about a dumb kid's glass and
getting [ __ ] up
combining like childhood nostalgia with
a drug
it is kind of it's so true i mean
gaffigan had that great joke he's like
something about the container like uh
you got a guy
drinking a wine glass with red wine
you're like hey but if you're like hey
refill my yahtzee shaker
yeah they don't make uh crack pipes with
crusty the clown on it i don't think
but it's a good point yeah
it's true it's weird on that we're like
it's in it weird how the carton or the
container makes it look like if you
drink whiskey
and pour in a rocks glass that's fine
but if you drink it out of the bottle
you look like a psycho and the same with
ice cream out of the carton
you're golden i mean you're you're a
weirdo but out of the bowl you're great
i do ice cream out of the carton all the
time i mean i do it too but i'm just
saying
if you put ice cream in a bowl you look
like a better
citizen yeah also here's i'll say this
so too with like booze
you're drinking you're drinking shitty
ass bourbon if you're if you're down to
just like backwash that [ __ ] back in
there
but uh yeah it is like a look thing like
in the in the
uh in the pint of ice cream you're like
all right this i'm ice cream is just
like an intimate snack now
like it's like you're alone at home
whereas like booze you're like oh i'm
gonna i can't wait to pour it into a
glass
i don't know why but it is ten times
sadder that's what it is you couldn't
take the time to put the ice cream in
the bowl you had to have it right then
that's how much of an addict you are
or the same with the alcohol yeah that's
interesting i
i never i was never an adult i guess
when you're a kid i mean you'll do 40s
and should
oh yeah but that's beer i think beer you
know you tend to drink it out of a
bottle
also what's sad is the the liquor in
plastic
the handle of liquor that's plastic like
the jug
that's a bummer yeah it is a bummer like
a jug of anything is kind of like
is it because jug doesn't sound classy
would you care for a jug right it sounds
like moonshine like it's got the three
x's on it
you don't even know what it is you're
just like all right it'll [ __ ] me up
i want to say good point just so our
listeners have to take a shot now
because i know that's one of our
our uh words good point they took a
drink
so what uh what were you sipping on
there that led to this uh
cocktail flu i did a lot of bourbon
just a lot of bourbon and and then a few
nights ago i went hard too
after a show i had this is i feel like a
real [ __ ] telling the story but i'll
tell it anyway
a friend of mine comes to shows all the
time and he always brings a hot date and
he always blows it
like it's become like a running gag of
how many hot dates
he'll bring and after the show
like it's me and phil hanley and a high
school friend of mine and we're just
like
we're bombed we're all wrecked yeah
drinking
and uh she's asking us the date if he's
a good guy and i have just enough booze
to be like he's such a good guy i mean
you know all his charity work have you
heard about his charity jerking off the
homeless
he's like he's looking at me like cut it
out cut it out i'm like
the homeless are freezing right now and
he jerks them to completion
because it's it's a real problem and
phil starts jumping in
we're just going we're just pounding on
him and he's so drunk that he's like
dude you promised
[Laughter]
that there's a real art to see i don't
know how he does it because he can get a
date but he can't close
i was the other way around if i got a
date i could close but it was hard for
me to get a date
well i think also like once she sniffs
that drunken insecurity it ain't good
because he is a he's a good dude he's a
cool dude but yeah
every once in a while if you're a bad
drunk you ain't closing
no god no and you ain't getting it up
either
but he should just fake the laughs
you look like a pro he grabbed phil at
one point it goes you're making a big
mistake and the girl is laughing
she's laughing so i'm like come on dude
but phil was like is he threatening me
i'm like hey he's gonna forget tomorrow
which i think he did but i was like he
did threaten you
yeah i hope phil went home with her i
mean phil's a smooth cat
he's in he's in a thing he's in a thing
oh
all right phil he's the most vague
secretive guy on the planet
he might have my favorite relationship
joke ever
when when you meet the right person you
know right away how come you meet the
wrong person it takes a year and a half
oh that's beautiful that's a good joke
that's got layers it's funny and so it's
well written and it's
poignant and it's one line yeah
that's comedy that's what comedy's
better than poetry
[Laughter]
what oh and so my boy dennis from
childhood is at the
uh show and we're hanging he's his dad
passed away a few years ago his dad was
like the coolest he was like the dad who
would go drinking with us
you're right he passed away he was so
funny he was like a vulgar
drunk uh we'd be at like we'd be at bars
and you'd walk up to women and be like
lady what i would give to take you in
the bathroom right now and they'd be
like
slap him it was like i remember that guy
he did that once and i said and i was
like oh my god i'm so sorry about him
this woman goes finally a gentleman and
she kissed me right in front of him
and he gave me a wink i'm like oh he's
doing this [ __ ] on purpose
he's digging a hole so that we get to
swoop in and be the hero
that's a great dad i mean what a guy
taking the hit for the
for the kids great friend i don't know
great dad
yeah great wing man great wingman i
don't know if he's paying the bills
no he was he was awesome he was a really
funny guy and
and this guy dennis who i see every once
in a while as a character and he's like
literally the last time i saw him he was
like i need your urine
and you can't ask why and i was like
it's a drug test and he goes
all right yeah it's a drug test
i literally met him with my urine at a
chipotle i was like here
jeez what did you put it in i i think
actually you know what i he gave me a
chipotle cup and
oh there you go i guess he asked for a
water cup i don't know we have a water
cup
which proves my point that no one has
ever put water in a water cup that's
your fault
even still um
yeah so that was we got into a lot of
i've just been
drinking too much it's that it's we're
getting to that point of the pandemic
where it's like
yeah it's winter in new york city yeah
i'm good and by the way i got rudy's
uh 44th and 9th just closed down behind
us my backdrop if you're watching us
it's done it was a legendary new york
bar if you guys didn't know it it was
like
there's like two affordable bars in
times square
yeah that aren't tourist traps rudy's
and jimmy's and jimmy
just died uh on 40 44 but rudy's man
remember the free hot dog with every
round
well i got drunk with bjorn remember
bjorn
the man he was you and joel's manager
yeah but he was just a booze bag
and we just got we he never did a lick
of work we just got drunk and paid for
everything
but back then you're like that's a good
manager exactly yeah i was like this
guy's the man he gets me he knows i'm an
artist
and you know you got the free hot dog so
i was just pounding beer eating pounding
beer and i
i leave the bar i lived in crown heights
by the way so
getting home was like an excursion so i
said i got a big ride ahead of me so let
me tell you what are you off to the four
five or the one or the two three were we
off i was off the a on no strand
ooh that's [ __ ] out down yeah yeah
yeah
so i was like all right i'm going to
take a little nap in an alcove that was
like four steps down into an apartment
and i was like this looks kind of warm
it's well lit just gonna rest my eyes
and i get down there i i conk out
immediately i wake up and like a bunch
of guys are going through my pockets
like four guys
and i was like what the [ __ ] i just did
this and one goes he's getting up and
just hit me and i went out again
i woke up they took my phone my wallet
my joke book my pen my keys my change i
was like
gee you took the joke book come on
you're a real comic because you said
joke book before keys that's how you
know you're
legit that's hilarious they they oh my
god it's awful but it's
i mean it's hilarious because you're
okay but like god damn dude those
four dudes yeah i mean i was a sitting
duck it was such an easy i was
i was a mark yeah literally i was so
easy it was like
i'm sleeping i'm a young guy there's
four of them
over i hate a [ __ ] it's like
you know what it's like people going
hunting against animals and you have a
gun it's like that's what four dudes
mugging one guy is they're hunting yeah
and at least shoot a deer in the in the
wild while he's grazing that i was a
sleeping deer you know like i was too
easy
brutal i just realized i was not
recording i have to restart this
i'm sure i'm sure harry can save it from
the from the zoom audio but
god damn harry my bad dude but yeah the
toughest thing is nobody tells you is
you're like all right well now i gotta
get home but you don't have
a metro card so you're like all right
now i gotta buy one but now you don't
have a credit card or
cash or a phone so you can't defend most
you can't so it's like getting home was
a nightmare had to jump to turn styles
and everything
oh it's like after hours martial edition
that's
man that's crazy they didn't even have
venmo in 2008 did they so i mean you had
like did they have uber in 2008
oh no i just had to go and i couldn't
get a cab either i had no money
no car no cash so i had to just take the
subway
and you were [ __ ] up and i was [ __ ]
up yeah so it was a long night
damn maybe i guess a pay phone was your
option back then i guess but they took
my quarters you know back then you had
three quarters in your pocket that was
that was some real loot
like that was useless yeah
i can't believe that [ __ ] [ __ ] rudy's
man yeah
yeah i mean that's a long that's a long
excursion there what uh what are you
drinking right now
oh yeah well i uh i always like to show
the people at home this is this is the
real deal we're going with clooney's
again
good good one yeah
cause amigos to quivila and uh my lady
got
uh some kind of drink with a lime in it
so i stole her lime
and her cup and i'm just going to
tequila
on the rocks with a splash of soda water
yeah that's i'm doing we're going
similar i'm doing
a splash of vodka with club soda because
i'm [ __ ]
dying right now i apologize my energy
sucks i didn't notice you having
bad energy last week oh i was i was
really faking it till i made it
so what's the hangover this is a booze
podcast basically what's the hangover
recipe from uh
from a true booze bag i make eggs i do
eggs tote i mean i had to go back to
sleep it was that bad but
uh yeah that helps uh i took like a 2
p.m nap which you're like man you feel
like a real piece of [ __ ] taking it it's
like it's not a power nap
it's like the opposite of whatever a
power nap is so i'm out
we a weakness nap failure now
i did that i did uh yeah i wake up i
make eggs
toast throw some cheddar in there some
turkey try to get some protein and some
it's what tastes good then i uh shitload
of drip drop
which is like the pedialyte it's like
the alternative
pedialyte that's good oh i don't know
that i think we called chlamydia
they got the drip drop it's uh
i think it's stronger than pedialy i
think it's got more electrolytes i could
be wrong but that's
oh wow that's what i that's what i heard
and i just went with it but uh
a little bit of that a lot of a lot of
water a lot of club soda
coffee no it did for the first time it's
gotta be like this
how bad like i i did coffee on friday
when i was hungover
i couldn't do it today what that's the
ultimate helper for me
like i'm i was that ill i couldn't keep
food down for a while
i couldn't keep until like five i
couldn't keep food down
so whoa yeah you are you are in bad
shape man
we're getting old i'm all right now last
week was in rough shape all right you
know
except i'm actually i was alright a few
weeks ago but now i'm in rough shape
no it's uh it's tough man uh i'll be
good tomorrow though
yeah yeah it's funny because when you're
hungover like this which i've been there
a million times you you want to kill
yourself you questioned every decision
you ever made you're like what do i do
with my life the anxiety
but at like 10 30 at night you're like
hey i feel pretty good and you almost
want to grab a beer
dude i mean here we are right you wake
up at 10 a.m i'll never drink again
2 p.m i'll drink again someday just not
right now
yes 9 p.m ah one won't hurt
yeah and then midnight you're in a
headlock again
right right it's like women who date
those you know [ __ ] abusive guys you
know
never again and two two years later
they're like ah frankie's nice when he
wants to be
yeah back with tito anyway
tito's not so bad no uh yeah it's uh
it's a mess man
this is so you're with a lady right now
at any valentine's day stuff or what
well uh luckily she had a thing tonight
and uh she was super hungover today so
we like ordered in
and had like you know the hangover sex
and like sideways on the couch
and nobody could move and i was on no
sleep so it was a beautiful
beautiful valentine i love when she's
hungover she's younger than me and she's
got all this energy
i want to just hang out that's huge it's
great too when they're
feeling like [ __ ] and you're like i
ordered and tie for you
you know what i mean like we're doing
the lazy day for you that's the best
i uh i don't you know what i hate is all
these flower websites that are like
like pro flowers uh 1-800 flowers
it's like it's like 30 and then you get
the checkout and it's like 110
and you're like how did that happen
service fee these cuts
these florist pieces of [ __ ] and these
these like
all of us douchebag uh procrastinating
idiot guys we wait till the last minute
they rack it up you know they know they
got you by the balls because you need
those flowers
[ __ ] flower guys yeah they they
should they should be like an amateur
flower website it should be like not as
good a job
and like you know what i mean dirt on it
still they took it out of a lawn
or a cemetery they just they don't like
they don't even like
deliver it perfectly like throw it
against your door you have to find it
you know
all right that's something um
yeah that's perv that's a perfect day i
was i was a bum today i didn't do [ __ ]
yeah i was glad because i was on no
sleep you know these these flights now
coming i'm doing all these midwest gigs
and it's like
six a.m or a seven a.m 7 p.m like that's
all you can get so you got to take the 6
a.m then you got to lay over in chicago
and that's a three-hour delay and it's a
whole thing that's
because there's just less flights yeah
yeah exactly that's
horrible those are horrible and it's
like we gotta you you want to get out
but [ __ ] i hate a 6 a.m flight
oh it was brutal and man i i gotta tell
you for some reason i flew out of
chicago to newark
and uh the whole flight was hasidic jews
which is fine but they all knew each
other
so they're like hanging out they're all
the aisle they're playing cards in the
aisle way all like the girls are on the
floor they're passing babies across from
me like oh yeah you know
i think i saw a kid get circumcised it
was bananas they're so comfortable the
masks were down here i was like
man these guys are living living the
life because they all they had the whole
plane so i felt like i was in borough
park
were they masked no they were hanging
low they were doing the the fake you
know the chin mask
oh i hate the trim mask yeah they uh
believe it but i was outnumbered
yeah it's funny i was talking to an
orthodox jewish girl once and she said
uh
for someone who just like started
talking about colin kaepernick she was
like i don't get it
she's like i just don't she's like i
don't get it like i don't understand it
and i was like all right well you want
to get a drink sometime and she's like
no i got a
7 000 person wedding to attend i can't
there you go uh yeah [ __ ] man that's
brutal that's brutal yeah
it was and they are you know they're up
and at them it was like the kids there
was so many kids and
you know the lady would come by the the
flight attendant and be like man your
mask
and she like oh she put it up and ran
with the lady walking away to go i like
roll her eyes i was like man these
these uh jews don't give a [ __ ] they're
just they're doing the havana gila
they're high-fiving it was
it was that stresses me out for travel
oh yeah because i'm getting back out
there soon i'm like oh boy
that's one where you're like all right
jews
it's like they're either the most
neurotic hypochondriac or they're
that yes you either get woody allen and
hannah and her sisters
where he's like i got a tumor i know it
and they're like you're fine
yeah or it's like borat
although i know he's what is he
kazakhstan kazakhstan uh
yeah man what uh good to be back good to
come back
i had a sunday show and i moved it to
saturday and i'm just coming back on a
sunday such a game changer
you did a third show you mean yeah we
out of the show
and uh did it like you know early in the
day did the blue room
oh it's a great room great great club
great time chris is so fun he showed me
the whole time we went to a bunch of
strip clubs and all that it was the
ozarks
you went to strip covered strip clubs
yeah the gals are wearing a mask
only because their their faces are bad
but like it was crazy just
we went out of stake and he's he's one
of these guys like i'm like i'm from new
orleans he's like i gotta show you the
town he just keeps taking me to strip
clubs i'm like i've seen
i've seen strip clubs this isn't weird
it's like that's [ __ ] hilarious i
live in manhattan
i need to show you the town oh yeah
let me see a strip club in the ozarks
that's that right
blow my mind coming from bourbon street
yeah it's it's
that's a great club though and that and
he's a great guy when i was there i
actually ended up in the hospital when i
was there
uh had some like horrible bug i don't
know what it was but i like could not
keep food down i couldn't
i couldn't eat i couldn't crap it was
like the worst
i ended up in the er with an iv in my
arm they're like yeah you got some bad
bug no food for 20 another 24 hours
i went straight from the hospital to the
gig did two shows they were the best
best crowd ever and my back was out and
he like paid for a massage for me he's a
great dude
he's really a great guy he kept buying
me things i was like stop stop like we'd
go to come and go which is their
7-eleven and he's like i'm buying you a
come and go t-shirt i'm like i don't
need the come and go t-shirt and he just
throws it at me he's like i bought it
like all right
when are you gonna wear this shirt i'll
wear it to bed i don't know
that's always the answer yeah but
anytime anytime you don't like a shirt
i'll wear it to bed
or go to the gym in it and then you're
like slow you find a gym shirt you're
like it's gone
why right i'll jizz in this
sleeve of this thing once in 10 years
and that'll be it i'll use to mop
up the the counter so disrespectful
with the jizz and a gift
[Laughter]
flashlight what are you gonna do i guess
if it's a flashlight but it's a weird
he's not gonna give you that have you
ever tried a fleshlight
i haven't i'm i'm shocked that i haven't
because i grew up [ __ ] the couch
[ __ ] the mattress [ __ ] the fridge
you know
all my friends were like if you heat up
half a cantaloupe it feels just like a
gash
so like i tried all these these remedies
you tried the cantaloupe
oh yeah i mean i had days off in the
summer what else was i doing
that's uh yeah it's weird they make
stuff specifically to [ __ ]
and that's where we draw the line i
think it's almost like it takes the
creativity out of it
yeah also i don't want to go to a store
and just what do you have to clean it or
it sounds like my hand's perfect why not
we're fine we're doing all right
i agree i like the idea of [ __ ] in
something and then just putting in the
wash or putting the garbage i don't want
to keep it around what is it dishwasher
safe
it's fun to go macgyver of snatch you
know like i don't think you put in the
dishwasher
i'm going to put it next to my cereal
bowl i don't think that's the
solution well i mean you ever seen
smacks they look like little vaginas
but i don't know it's just like do i do
i wash it
in the dish to the sink i mean what do
you do you got to wash it somewhere or
do you just let it
i think you you wash it in the sink but
you got to make sure all the dishes are
out
you don't want that going in the coffee
pot you know yeah that's true cream in
the coffee but i just
i don't i don't to me that's sadder
somehow than actually
using a fleshlight it's washing the jizz
out of course i think i was like my
cannon did a bit about this where it was
like
the cleaning was the was the part that
drove him insane i think it's horrible
there you go yeah i'd rather a sock give
me a wigwam any day
oh wait a wig would you you ruin a sock
i don't think they wash you put the
washer
yeah it's on your foot the rest of the
time it's not like we're treating these
things like a
like a pillow i go green i shoot it in
the hand and i'm done with it
what yeah i go green mine's too uh
it's like a sawed-off shotgun i'm gonna
spread
yeah i guess i've done it i mean this is
going to sound gross i've done you have
done
the bathroom sink before oh same i just
feel like that's
uh it's just an easy way like all right
let's clean i i just i don't like
cleaning
no well you're a tall guy too so you
have better you better aim at it like
from an upper level you know
i don't think you're struggling with aim
into a sink i think you're all right
well if you if you you know mugsy bogues
or danny devito
you know you might have to get on a
squatty potty to get the height
danny devito's got little doggy stairs
to jerk off into the sink
like the kids with the teeth brushing
he's he's next to them
these stairs [ __ ] i so many dumb ads
over the years
like doggy stairs was one of the dumbest
ones of all time
yeah but that's squatty potty that made
millions
yeah that one makes sense so i think
yeah and actually
my friends likes he swears by it i go to
his apartment it's sitting right there
are there any is there anything else
that was like huge like i definitely i
mean
was shamwow big or was it just mocked i
think it was pretty big i mean the guy
cleaned up
uh it you know like auto places would
buy it and uh
car wash places so they would all get it
then you had the pet rock guy made a
couple
couple mil how about slap chop was that
big
no what is that that was when i remember
slap chop you just slap
you slap stuff and then you chopped the
food i don't know oh i don't know that
oh the
oh the uh what do you call it the george
foreman grill that's probably what
that's done
hulk hogan turned it down whoa
a lot of dough so it wasn't made by
foreman i thought he thought of it
no i think it was like someone made it
and i'm let me factuate that right now
but i
remember hogan i heard hogan say that he
turned it down um
wow that's like uh
will smith turning down the matrix
will smith is getting more movie options
these days than hulk hogan
that's true but i i blame the uh i mean
look the guy did well but i blame the
entrepreneur whoever made the form
michael c boom that guy should be
getting out there and selling his own
product that's what you do
i guess but maybe maybe it's way i mean
it's a george foreman grill it's like
maybe that's why it's that big although
it's like
the opposite of stallone right rocky he
was like this is my baby i'm in rocky
they offered him more money stallone
still was like i'm rocky
exactly this dude went the other way he
was like no this is george foreman
yes you gotta own it i mean it's your
product uh papa john the my pillow guy
any of somebody else who says the n word
you know you gotta own your product you
gotta get behind it and you
are the face of it but hey look my the
george foreman did great but you're
going to lose
30 of the profits going to foreman
huh yeah i wonder i mean that is
i wonder who would have been like the
next choice after hogan
former foreman turns it down who's your
who's your next guy
i mean you can have lou ferrigno but
that's too too too much of a bummer
he's got the speech impediment uh i was
gonna say muhammad ali
the whole parkinson thing might be an
issue too it's like a thing where it's
all about
precision coming down he's more for the
shake weight
uh all right i had to do it had to
shake weight was that big oh yeah that
had a its moment in the sun
i don't think i see it at jim's just
sitting there nobody ever uses it
because it's too embarrassing
it's ridiculous it's around people
bought it uh the nutribullet
had had a real good time that's just a
blender though isn't it
it is but it was quick and one push or
two push you know
it's a gimmick yeah what anything else
are we missing anything
wasn't there something where you [ __ ]
you cut your hair and it vacuums it
remember that i don't know that might
have been the 80s it's also like those
teflon pans do pretty well
clap on clap clap i bought a clapper
what yeah that was good
that was the original alexa
when you think about it because you
didn't have to move yeah
it was really like every [ __ ] hack
joke too was like i'm looking i got a
standing o
i [ __ ] her i got to stand you know
yeah yeah i was i'm sure that was huge
for the
hmm the problem with the clapper though
is it never worked when you wanted it to
like you're at home
clap and it would turn off but when you
had friends over you're like watch this
hold on you know it never worked when
you needed to
yeah and it's also one of the things
like you're like it was the most
depressing ad it was like basically the
lady from the life alert commercial she
was just like
and then she rolled over and you're like
that's the whole [ __ ] ad yeah
that was it oh what about the craftmatic
adjustable bed had it had a moment
well oh that that would make the bed
like kind of go up yeah so the old
people could sit up and watch tv and my
grandparents
had that there you go that was i got
around that was big
that was big the adjustable you know
it's kind of a nice thing
actually if you think about it it's kind
of it's kind of cool yeah and this is
what
this is the 90s when like there wasn't
as much competition like
if you got a invention together there
was no shark tank there was no amazon
there was no website you had to get on
tv
and hock that product
yeah damn that's a good point now it's
like
you can just put a website out or a
youtube video hey look what i made it's
pretty cool
apple bought it for 2 billion whatever
but back then it was like
this is all me in a garage in
indianapolis
now i gotta get it get a tv commercial
crazy different times man what uh what
are you watching you got any wrecks
reading anything watch anything movie
anything yeah well
i just finished well i don't know if i
finished it because it's still going but
the lady and the dale
you're doing this yet i hear it's
amazing i gotta get out i'm like a doc
behind you or two
it's unbelievable unbelievable i read
about it so i know i mean i just read
the story
because i was curious but it's yeah it's
insane yeah
it's crazy this this woman who did this
whole journey is like so
ballsy and weird and criminal and
adventurous
and then i'm only on episode three but i
think the other one hasn't come out yet
but these netflix the hbo duploss
brothers from new orleans by the way oh
yeah they're great
but netflix these [ __ ] guzzlers they
stretch out these docu-series for 12
episodes they don't
need to like which ones give me one that
make it a murderer that was too long too
long i'm watching this other one now
that ron howard just did about the lady
who died at the
cecil hotel in l.a and they found her in
the water tower
it's like a classic old true crime story
but they finally did a dock about it and
it's so
drawn out they just keep saying the same
things over and over again you're like
then each episode they give you one
nugget and you're like all right now i
got to watch another one
but yeah everyone's talking about that
one yeah
i forgot what it's called making a
murderer drove me nuts the only long one
that i was okay with
was uh the staircase because it was
i know you loved that one it was good
but yeah [ __ ] man yeah they're all too
just get it done just just tell the [ __ ]
i watched tiger because of you i watched
the tiger woods oh
again hbo killed it so [ __ ] good
there was that one line the tiger won
uh where some journalist comes on and
goes once you conquer the world the
world is gonna want us revenge
i was like oh my god [ __ ] heavy
tiger woods you feel bad for that dude
because he
he was so [ __ ] good but he was like a
more machine than man
definitely definitely the only part of
the only man thing about him was his sex
drive and his ego
like he was so competitive you know he's
like
who whatever that australian guy was the
good golfer i forgot his name cool guy
mick or nick i can't remember nicholas
maybe maybe that's
it handsome guy and that was the one
where tiger was like
yeah that was a pretty good hit but i
usually hit it harder or hit it longer
and the guy was like
not mickelson is it mickelson bill
mickelson he's not australian i was from
california
oh well who the hell am i he was he was
hilarious because he's just like a
chubby dude with all the goods and tiger
[ __ ] hates him he's just like a fat
dude who could
he's not even fat but like he's not
tiger he's not he doesn't look like an
athlete for sure
yeah tiger's like ripped out there in a
polo shirt but
yeah it's just like hey man relax have
some fun but he couldn't do it but
i part of me is like is that what you
got to do to be that good
is there a balance
ever probably to be the best athlete
i mean [ __ ] dude to get where he got
and whenever and yeah i think maybe you
have to like
it's a combination of like physical
gifts
that you're born with but then also
having a dad who like
yeah so weird that his dad like it's
kind of it's weird because he's two
years old on what it was like
some show some talk show merv griffin or
some [ __ ] yeah
and he's hitting the ball bob hope yeah
and he's hitting the ball and you're
like oh this you're smiling you're like
this is amazing but you're like man it's
also kind of sick
yeah that you're like true but then it's
like the people judging it's like
why aren't you doing this [ __ ] with your
kids on tick tock
if you're a kid if your kid was that
good
you'd be milking that [ __ ] for [ __ ]
views too great point
great point it is it is [ __ ] up
the dad just he's just banging women in
his trailer well tiger's just out
hitting balls so were those prostitutes
no i think he like gave women golf
lessons and he just had game i think
that was
damn it's good for him i mean crazy to
do that in front of your kid he's
cheating on his wife but like
i'm impressed that he could pull these
like they were like he's pulling these
hot young blondes i'm like how this guy
looks like uh
you know uncle ben on the rice box he's
not even that good looking of a guy
but hey his name was what was his name
like mordecai
or archibald or some [ __ ]
some old guy name he uh
he just kind of looked like a little
puffy he was like like a puffy dude he
just yeah
he look he looked like a [ __ ] north
face you know
[Laughter]
yeah no he uh he would
pull chicks i think he was also i think
when you're like a good athlete which he
was he obviously wasn't tiger but he was
like an athlete and he was
in the war i think some of those dudes
just have like a [ __ ] swagger and
kind of like
i think when you've once you've done
that [ __ ] you're like yeah i'll [ __ ]
ask for a number
you know yeah so true i've seen charlie
you know whizzing bullets by my head and
i you know watch when one of my friends
die i can hit on this
uh tiffany yeah dude i mean he and he
was the best
uh i mean like at like 19 he was like
the [ __ ] best
unbelievable yeah and it's this is gonna
sound harsh but it's still crazy how
good he was
and his rise and fall and he still
didn't beat mickelson's record
did he not which one what was his record
well he's got like
some crate like 42 green jackets or
opens or whatever you call it
yeah and tiger has like 39 or something
and you're like
i don't know enough about golf but isn't
tiger still considered the greatest oh
for sure
he's a better golfer he just never got
there because mickelson's been around
for
65 years or whatever maybe not that long
no he's only five years older than tiger
they said he also uh
yeah he's not that much older well he
does look terrible then
he i mean i don't think he's that old
i thought he was like 75 phil mickelson
uh who am i thinking of i thought galt
these golfers were like old honkies
phil mickelson well he was the guy going
against so he's 50. he's not that old
oh geez all right well i'm the wrong guy
here well anyway
uh yeah no it's [ __ ] incredible
though and tiger
like i felt bad from i remember rachel
you could tell used to come to gary
veeder's shows remember that it was your
show with gary
really yeah she was at the show
irish exit yeah i saw her in the crowd
once she she was a good laugher so she's
that's all i'm like yeah she tore his
family apart but you know what she
laughed
yeah jokes one time and she no she
seemed enthusiastic gary
said she was super nice always wow i'm
i'm kind of into her she's kind of
something about her she's just so down
and trashy and fun like i don't want to
marry the lady but something about her
it's fun
well i think that was maybe the problem
with tyke
exactly like this chick's fun i don't
want to marry her
well then don't [ __ ] that was the
[ __ ] up thing is that like he didn't
just have
affairs he like let them think he was in
love with all of them
right right they all were like he broke
my heart i'm like jesus you're not just
cheating on your wife like you have bad
cheating etiquette
like there's right and apparently they
were pissed because he didn't pay for
[ __ ] like even in the documentary she
was like so i flew to florida i'm like
he didn't [ __ ] fly you out yeah oh
wow i missed that that's him yeah he
didn't fly you
places yeah that's making it 100 million
a year
and he can't [ __ ] get you jet blue
mint or something
yeah i mean right what the [ __ ] oh
that's horrible i didn't know that but
yeah i think they say psychologically
you do that whole
thing with women where you go like i
love you you're special to me
my wife don't worry about her you mean a
lot to me i'm in love with you because
you feel bad about what your mom's been
through
they say that's the oh wow his mom was
through a lot
yeah so it's in a weird way it's like i
feel horrible with my dad as my mom so
i'm gonna make these women feel good
um well short term i guess yeah
they were not happy with him i mean
that's
crazy it's also hilarious to think of
tiger woods just in vegas out with
mj and charles barkley he's just like
the geeky one
yep yep yep so true now here's a
horrible question that nobody wants to
hear
yeah but i can't help myself from
thinking it or asking it but no one's
listening so
hey i'm throwing it out there i don't
think that's true i think people are
listening
oh [ __ ] wow maybe i brought this up
before but if you
are a black and asian
you got the huge dong on the black side
the tiny dong and the asian
does it meet halfway or do you think you
still go black dog
you know i don't know i don't i'm not
it's an interesting question
i think if we're basing this purely off
stereotypes
yes i think he's doing all right all
right i figure he wants to be my guest
because he's built more black i'd say
all right all right ripped asian guys
have you seen bruce lee
yeah but he's still petite i'd say he's
thin
he's built no i all right i hear you so
he's like he shredded
hmm it's a it's a question
i think sometimes swagger says a lot too
and he had swagger he did have swag well
if you're that good
you got you know that's yeah that is the
other thing just being great will give
you swagger yeah i don't know
it's a that's a great we'll have to go
to the listeners who
do you think it's huge tiny
or in the middle and we're basing this
only off stereotypes of course yes
obviously some black guys have tiny
dongs and some asian guys i'm sure have
huge dongs but i'm just going off the
what i've seen in the video that sounded
condescending you said i'm sure
like you're like going off some myth and
look i'm sure it's possible
right that's gotta be kind of fun maybe
maybe it's a gamble but like [ __ ] if
you're a girl who [ __ ] white dudes a
lot
every white dude is is it's like uh who
knows
you know it's up in the air because i've
seen some white guys i know a
huge dong and i've seen white guys i
know with tiny and so every woman's like
going in
completely blind interesting i guess you
could say the same with a vagina but
it's not
it's not the same like wow i guess
there's not the range
right right maybe the outdoors look a
little
messy or or clean the porch is messier
cleaner but the inside is usually pretty
similar
yeah the interior is the same i'd say
yeah
uh yeah that's a good point is the uh
the penis
a gamble it is a gamble you're going in
it's kind of like watching a movie
and not reading anything about it yeah
that's great that's great or we're
seeing a comic you're just like we're
gonna see comedy
and then sometimes you get gaff again
and sometimes you get [ __ ] uh you
know corey holcomb
crazy reference there you got to be a
godly fan to get that one
um interesting so i realize it's
inappropriate
no it's it's interesting what about so
i'm a tiger yeah that was my
favorite doc in a while that one was
that's my wreck this week your wreck is
what was it again
well i was just i got a different wreck
you were asking what i was watching
okay i'm trying to mix it up with the
wrecks
because i feel like every time i give a
documentary or a movie
so i'm going with something then this is
perfect for me and you you showed me
this
in i don't know 2012
2013 we went to montreal we were in your
your hotel room which was filthy we're
pre-gaming before a show
and i mentioned your your facial hair
and i was like you're all your facial is
always perfectly
even and you know not long but not short
and you said you gotta get this shaver
oh the norelco the norelco
i love this thing i've had it since you
told me about it i bought it the next
day on amazon
i've had the same one it's the best
thing i i rarely charge it it cuts
perfectly
this we were talking about late night
infomercials that just kind of looked
like one for a second
this is the best thing i use it every
night
right then you get the black and white
where i'm like
no i love that thing i use it i use it
constantly
starburst she has one for his pubes and
one for his face
perfect yeah those greek pubes i'm sure
need a need a real trimming but yeah um
yeah i love it i like this so we're
doing more than just i like this wreck
thing
we can do anything yeah i'm branching
out i'm outside the box because last
week i did a band this week i'm doing
that and i'm also gonna
oh nice
well i'm a big uh self-help douche with
uh
you know these these motivational queefs
and all these guys and i love all this
this zen buddhist [ __ ]
and all these like successful tips and
if you if it's self-help is too
pretentious and too annoying
a good way to transition is a youtube
channel called
after school and school with a k
and they illustrate it all so they you
they play some
guy like some tim ferris type guy and
he's talking
and they illustrate it while he's
talking and it makes it so much more
captivating
so much more accessible and they all the
art is really cool
and they pick great little clips to put
up and uh i can't recommend it enough
that sounds good i was just running
after school i just pictured like mary
kay letourneau
[Laughter]
uh no that's [ __ ] that sounds great
that sounds cool i love
i love stuff where you like i mean i got
into i listened to a few episodes of
malcolm gladwell's podcast because you i
like i like your wrecks man i go i go
right to him
oh thanks yeah you know you try to try
to branch out it's all about
open-mindedness and new things and
there's so much [ __ ] out there that we
just
you know we stay in our little tunnel we
go i like this i like this i'm sticking
with it but if you
you branch out there's so much great
[ __ ] it's so true i'm the king of that
and it's like
man it's a pandemic you got to mix it up
your life is the same
i got to stop watching the sopranos and
the simpsons all the time i gotta chill
so
yeah it's good well said i'm going to do
that for sure
i'll check out after school joe liz
bought a mandolin
he's like i always want to try mandolin
and i was like yeah what the [ __ ] so i
bought a piano i bought a keyboard
really it's on the way it's shipping
right now are you going to become like
galifianakis on stage now
no god no no no i love zach but
are you going to do like dimitri martin
[ __ ] where you just do like one liners
yeah i got an easel coming and a
projector but no i
i just want to be the guy you know when
you're at a party it's kind of dead
and you know you're looking around
you're like what is that you blow the
dust off you pop the little
little cover off
[Laughter]
everybody starts dancing and somebody
throws you a beer you know you chug the
beer
i like that your vision is just like
you're just like the dude in the
heineken commercial
yeah yes exactly the fun guy in every
80s comedy
every day every dangerfield movie for
some reason he would just start singing
and it made me notice
like like uh [ __ ] back to school meet
while he sparks he's singing with all
the wives
goodness greatness great balls of fire
just like why is this in the movie
i know it was that his idea i don't know
it's so funny though a pretty girl gets
on the piano starts dancing and she
kisses me
i have my ties like on my forehead for
some reason yeah i can't wait
i love it i love it you're gonna be this
is good i know this
i'm going to be at a [ __ ] party with
you hopefully sooner rather than later
yeah
and this shit's going to [ __ ] you're
just going to go right forward i'm going
to be like oh this is this is what it
paid off is what it was for
yep yep exactly and it's going to be a
nightmare learning how to play and
getting the finger strength and all that
but
i'm going to pan that what else am i
doing yeah i should do something
productive
i say that i won't but i i i should
start thinking about
something you write a lot at least and
you know you got a couple pods and you
got
uh yeah you got stuff playing ball
sometimes yeah
and you read i play ball
oh yeah and you play ball good exercise
i do some stuff
yeah but it's not new something new i
feel like that's good for your brain i
feel like that's got to be
agreed what any pet peeves
uh yeah yeah oh we should do this ad too
oh yeah let's do an ad speaking of pet
peeves i'll tell you what's not a pet
peeve
lucy's nicotine gum have you tried this
mark
i have i'm a fan great flavors so good
right you got a
pomegranate you got uh cinnamon
wintergreen
i mean you're gonna like you know how
women kiss you and they're like you
taste like [ __ ] you're a smoker
now you actually taste good and you
still get that four gram
of nicotine rush because it's hard to
quit smoking right mark
oh it's got to be the hardest thing out
there i mean there's books and tapes on
it
people people kill themselves over this
[ __ ] so
get this gum and if you don't like gum
get the the lozenges they got cherry
iced lozenges they taste great
the gum tastes really good it's got the
the nicotine in it and get rid of those
cigarettes unplug your vape
throw out your dip and get a pack of
lucy do yourself a favor and subscribe
it'll show up at your doorstep each
month and you'll
always be ready get out there and create
a better and cleaner
you with a nicotine alternative yep
they're uh supporting the show so go
support them 20
off all products including gum or
lozenges at lucy.co
with code drunk that's 20 off lucy.co
promo code drunk uh so clearly you know
this sounds like a good deal and and
here's the part the lawyers will make us
say
warning the product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco
nicotine is an addictive chemical but
you already knew that so 20
off lucy.co with code drunk
yes there you go all right now
you gave me your wreck what was your
wreck tiger woods okay okay
uh so i gotta tell you this pet peeve
and this is this is gonna be another
weird one because i get
annoyed by weird [ __ ] but uh you ever
have this one
you're uh some guy he's telling you a
story or telling you
a fun fact or something and you start
laughing and they go no no i'm serious
yeah yeah yeah i know but it's still
funny and like no no i'm serious like
yeah all right but i still can find
serious stuff funny
and they're like i'm telling you man
this guy murdered three people like wow
three people no seriously i'm like yeah
i know
that's why it's funny he was butt naked
when he did it you're like laughing he's
like
seriously his dick was wiggling
everywhere yes
yes i'm aware it's serious it's i've
just got a [ __ ] up sense of humor baby
let me laugh
also there's that line from that uh that
bare naked lady song i came up according
to the bear like
bear naked ladies but i'm the type of
guy that laughs at a funeral i'm like
that's
every comedian right doesn't mean we're
bad people we're [ __ ]
we laugh at weird [ __ ] good point yeah
your
people are attracted to other stuff let
me be attracted to
uh horrible humor we're dead inside we
need to
you know we've just we've explored
everything else so we need
maybe an extra jolt of darkness to jump
start you know
this is our life dark it's like of
course dark jokes you think like [ __ ]
hookers just
only bang missionary yeah exactly we're
getting choked of comedy probably i
don't know like that's
like a dark joke here and there yeah i
mean some priest
preacher can can kick back with a high
life we're like hey how about an eight
ball
and a tequila you know like we have to
kick it up a notch
we're in too deep we're in 2d man yeah
i totally i'm totally with you people
get annoyed at me though do not
laugh and i'm like how do you tell
someone not to laugh
i don't know exactly you let them
[ __ ]
yeah i don't know i'm with you i'm
serious yeah
yeah i know exactly who cares it made me
laugh it triggered an involuntary
response like
you telling me it serious isn't going to
change how i am
yeah it's weird it's kind of like it's
usually someone who doesn't really know
you though
right right it's like if they're really
going to be like
if they're really going to be like uh
you know
why are you laughing at that you're like
well you don't you don't know me
yeah yeah and and to be clear it's not
always about offensive stuff like it
could just be about anything like this
dude bought another couch and i'm like
oh wow another cat
i'm serious i'm like yeah i know it's
just funny you bought another
couch i believe you they i think they
think you don't believe them
i sometimes laugh harder in dark movies
than i do
in comments oh yeah silence of the lambs
is hilarious
like put it the bunny in the bun what is
it uh the lotion in the basket come on
are you doing con air there for a second
i got screwed up with the bunny in the
box
good catch um yeah con air is
the hilarious is [ __ ] funny by the
way young dave chappelle in that
she's gonna say that can you imagine
being that
comic at that age like i'm working with
nicholas cage john cusack
like john malkovich what the [ __ ]
yeah i mean he worked with mel brooks
when he was even younger right i mean
robin and my tights he just was probably
not starstruck at that point i would
think i guess but at least mel brooks
i feel like you know he's a legend and
like a hero of mine but he's
he's still a comedian and in the in the
mix this is like
a level hollywood [ __ ] you know yeah
dude is there anyone who's more
uh hit or miss than nicolas cage in
history
i'd say more miss but i mean leaving las
vegas is unbelievable
yeah he's great in that movie it's also
like uh
he is you know what he is he's the i
don't know what this white dude's penis
is going to look like
of movies
yes great great girls right leaving las
vegas
adaptation's incredible raising arizona
raising arizona incredible
great so great yeah so true and he can
act when he wants to but he just picks
these ghost riders and
moonstruck is great oh moonstruck he's
hilarious in that
it's so [ __ ] funny in that movie and
i i heard he had like
like a ton of gambling debts and has to
take these movies to pay that's what i
heard
that's that's actually i don't want to
see that movie it's just like a fake
nicholas cage
just on set of shitty movies played by
nicholas cage
talking to some bookie but like even but
he's like
he's like bad lieutenant nicholas cage
in a nicholas cage movie
right right also not a bad movie but
uh face-off is like objectively silly
and ridiculous but i enjoy the hell out
of it yeah me too
yeah it's so i mean it's i guess we
found the other guy who is the most hit
or miss is travolta
oh yeah yeah yeah that's true i mean i
i don't want to say adam sandler because
he we're fans but i mean he's had some
real
some real misses too like jack and jill
comedy is i think comedy is also like
i thought quick was pretty good actually
oh really
come on i didn't hate it i thought it
was i i'm
maybe i'm one of the only ones that was
like and it's a wonderful life vibe i
don't know
[Music]
christopher walken was so good in it i
like walking
but um no comedy i think i think every
big comedian is in hit or miss movies
i mean like kevin hart isn't you know
uh [ __ ] uh does he have a hit jim
carrey come on like everyone's
yeah yes everyone's hit or miss i'm
talking like big
big a-list you know like will ferrell's
been
duds he's one of the funniest dudes ever
yeah he's amazing uh what what what will
ferrell i feel like they just they just
say like a
a genre of a sport and then will ferrell
like
ice skating and will ferrell we'll take
it car racing and will ferrell we'll
take it
basketball pharah we'll take it you know
it's it's just him it's all him
yeah they were all pretty good i didn't
see that i didn't see semi-pro but i
thought i mean i
i just kind of like will ferrell man uh
talladega knights is
great insane so good sasha baron cohen
is great in that
yeah what do you think of the new borax
did you like it i actually never
saw it i got it i'm not a huge borat guy
i love
baron cohen's stuff i love ollie g and i
love the first borat i saw in the
theater was unbelievable
but i get as i get older i'm not crazy
about the
tricking people and making him look
stupid and that's the joke
i just feel bad for them and like they
tend to be a lot of idiots and yokels so
that makes it even weirder to me
that's interesting you know what i've
kind of felt similarly about like i i
love bill maher's show
i'll listen to bill maher's show every
week you know uh
it's like bill maher's super you know
he's a super smart guy
and he's like and he's like [ __ ] with
like cadillac priests where i'm just
like
these dudes aren't [ __ ] legit i know
they have big followings but it's like
you're dealing with idiots here and then
and then occasionally you get like a
politician like this should have been
the whole movie
totally yeah going after smart con man
right right yeah yeah i'm with you like
he's in a like a
gun salesman or a trailer park church
and you're like dude these people need
this [ __ ]
like they're down and out they're all
addicts and recovering and [ __ ]
don't that felt like very hollywood you
know but as i said i'm a
fan of the show i think the show is
great i think it shows great too i think
he keeps it real and all that
but yeah that was a little tough i'm
with you and i'm from the south too so
there's like a little bit of like a
all right easy easy on these [ __ ]
rednecks well yeah
they're just trying to survive what
about um
yeah that's interesting i i totally see
what you're saying that's what i kind of
like about impractical jokers because i
feel like it's them
[ __ ] with each other yes yeah it's a
brilliant comedy
move same with jackass they're shooting
each other out of a cannon they're
running away from bulls they're shooting
each other with like a stun gun
it's them it is weird it is weird to
like pitch or like
yeah i just [ __ ] with strangers on the
street and you're like yeah we all
[ __ ] hate that guy
but we're watching yeah yeah i don't
know
i don't like it i i don't i feel like
and also there's a lot of hypocrisy with
like the politics stuff like you'd be
mean to this side because i'm not on
this side but
if you're mean to that side it's mean
but you should be compassionate and i
i don't know it's all very strange so
yeah i know i like the
the we're friends and we're [ __ ]
we're the butt of the joke that's my
favorite
of the hidden camera thing and the same
goes with stand up if you're if a
stand-up she's up there going this group
sucks [ __ ] you you gotta hit yourself
every now and then you gotta be humble
and be human
too you you always tell me that like
i'll have a joke you're like
it would work better if you [ __ ] on
yourself in the beginning
and i'm like you're right yes i mean
that's why every comic
almost every comic will open
self-deprecating on late night or
something to get that quick kind of
you know so yeah hey heads up i i don't
like me either you know
yeah marines have this great opener
where he would
come out on stage and go uh all right
take a moment to judge me
i remember that i sleep on conan but
it's like
you need that quick joke where you like
show your i think it's
that was great because it's like sure
that shows self-awareness as well you
know so it's like you want to show them
that you're
aware yeah yeah totally like it's a
hacky move but
it works like a charm when the comic
goes i know i know i look like this and
that guy
[ __ ] her i looked like john goodman
[ __ ] at a coke machine
or whatever the [ __ ] it is you know and
it always hits because i go you do
yeah br the it's the icebreaker right
right
exactly but yeah if you show yourself i
mean look if there's a way to make
sometimes
the joke is only funny if you're
[ __ ] on someone else though
i'm not i'm not against it yeah it's not
like a perfect recipe but like if you
can make it about you
yeah that i think i think helps yeah
yeah agreed all right you got a uh what
did i just give you
the pet peeve yeah you got a pet you
when you laugh
when they la when you laugh and they go
you know what i mean you're asking what
you said
no what did you what did you just my pet
peeve is uh
all right i have a few i got to choose
one i've always done a few things
bugging me
um this bugs me when people
go he's got a family
oh that's like a defense for someone
being a piece of [ __ ]
give him a break he's got a family i'm
like so i can't
do i have to like be an incredible human
being because i don't have a family
yeah what the [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
everybody's got a family that you're
only existing because of your family let
me unless they all
i think they mean he's got a wife and
kids yeah okay
i gave i gave a friend of ours [ __ ] he
goes he's a good guy he smokes cigars
and he's got a family i'm like that's
all it takes
i was like what so i i'm a piece of i
drink green juice i'm a piece of [ __ ]
and i'm single you know right
that's a great point it's so anybody i
mean every tom dick and harry's gotta
fail you just [ __ ] in some
some skank and she had a she didn't have
birth control so now i'm gonna be nice
to you
yeah get maybe i'm actually a better
person because i didn't i didn't dump a
load in a stranger
and yes know that i wouldn't probably be
ready to be a father so
i i i hate the uh
he's got a family that's a great catch
because you people say that all the time
you go all right all right but
yeah [ __ ] that why are we letting that
be a thing
let me do one more because i'm with you
there's another one
when people go i love you but
they probably i love you but and you're
like all right
what is it and they're like can you
lower the volume and you're like
why do you have to tell me you love me
before that just say hey do you mind i'm
sorry just lowering the volume
how soft do you think we are as people
that you have to cushion that
with hair i love you what does your love
have to do
right it's it's pretty shitty that's
that's a
a sloppy uh lazy version of the humbling
thing that we were just talking about
i love you but can you uh can you hand
me the salt shaker
like just asking for the [ __ ] salt
shaker don't try to
you're trying to ask for something but
still be a good guy
it's totally transparent i don't like
that either i hate that
um yeah so those are my two big ones i'd
say
yeah you know what else on that same in
that same ballpark is the uh
i had a friend who would change his
voice he would like go down a few
octaves when he would ask for something
you know he'd be like hey yeah you know
can you get me around to the airport
like he would try to sound cuter or
something women
women do that in the cabs when they need
a favor excu
or the excuse me can i have a cigarette
yes
yes they do that's dead on
we can see through it skanks we can't do
that to it
excuse me sir excuse me
can i have a camel
that's true oh that's hilarious
i have to try that excuse me
the guy would give it to you just like
whoa he's gotta get away
i bet that guy exists in the west
village honestly
can i have your coat buddy
yeah i hate the voice change excuse me
okay i got one more
one last one all right i got a lot of
these i look like a prior set
so carlin my friend here's another
people who deserve an inoperable tumor
at the base of their spine
[Laughter]
here's another group of people who has
which health plan included abortion
i love dude the best you know the best
one in that special is
is when he goes uh people who say my
daddy
well my daddy used to say
you know what my daddy used to say [ __ ]
uh it's not even great writing but it's
so fun
it's not a good joke but it gets me
every time like i'm like that's not a
joke but i laugh every time i hear it he
got real loose on that special and i was
100 behind it where he goes you know
what i hate guys named todd
what the what basis do you have for
hating god you've never met
every everybody named todd he's like you
know what i like a guy named eddie
you're like i love where you're going i
get it but
man you are taking some this is a big
jump here
i'll tell you though i listen to that
special a lot it's a funny that's a
that's a [ __ ] funny one man
you're right it's so loose is that
complaints and grievances or is that
back in town
no it's complaints and man i
used to listen to my college dorm like
fist pumping
yeah i would laugh so hard but i i
really listen every now and then i'm
like yeah
it might not be as good as i remember it
but i still i still love it
yeah dude i mean those old carlins have
you listened back now like how much has
changed with like
uh all like that you gotta can't say
that and canceling it is so
harsh a lot of the [ __ ] he's saying like
he says the n word a few times and
he's like you know what i call feminists
a come catcher you're like
whoa i can't believe he's saying this
[ __ ] to a microphone
it's weird how he would be like so
reasonable at times and then so unreal
and you're kind of like that's [ __ ]
car you just
i think you just go in going like yeah
if you're a carlin fan
you gotta know you're not gonna love
everything you hear that night
but it was that funny it didn't [ __ ]
matter exactly
and you could tell he was a good guy he
was on the right side of everything but
he still
just like making [ __ ] up jokes which i
think is the best kind of comedian agree
you know like he's gonna do abortion
stuff he's gonna do
uh black jokes and feminists making fun
of family making fun of women but like
he's like we gotta take down these
politicians these priests are [ __ ]
kids like he was always
the war is stupid like he was on the
right side but we gotta take down these
pedophiles we gotta date on these
politicians we gotta take down guys and
visors
what's up with guys that wear their hats
hats backwards you're 48
jeff turn that [ __ ] head around or
whatever it is
[ __ ] he's ridiculous um here's
another one
oh wow all right so i got my friend got
invited to
everything's on zoom now i'm going nuts
i did a zoom
benefit the other night you know to
raise money for this like rotary club in
connecticut and uh this woman starts
first off she starts heckling me in the
thing
it's a guy and i go [ __ ] you steven you
[ __ ] [ __ ] so i start trashing him
and then he goes this is his wife vivi
and i go oh i [ __ ] hate you so
so i just started piling on it felt so
satisfying to destroy someone with a mic
i'm like people have so much [ __ ]
confidence behind a keyboard you know
yeah
but then when you start turning on them
and all the other people on the
keyboards are like
[ __ ] her get her i'm like yes oh that's
great it was satisfying but my point of
this is
zoom everything on zoom like my friend
goes i got invited to a zoom bris
wow a zoom hilarious are we not taking
this too we can't do a private bris now
you're going to make me watch you
[ __ ] you even watch your baby get
circumcised without free bagels or
coffee
that's the point you're going there for
the hang on
right right it's a family affair it's a
tradition or a religious thing like
this doesn't need to be zoomed i'm not
going to assume baptism either it's too
much
you know what i would say i was like hey
can you give me recording uh clearance
can i record this too
yeah you don't have a tubing situation
or a jubin
but it's just crazy because like now i'm
watching a baby dick on my computer this
is
my whole life is about not ever doing
that now it's happening what's even
weirder is i've got another window open
with a baby dick
exactly i don't know which baby drink to
watch
um those are my those are my things what
do you any any news stories anything
good
i'm a machine like this yeah i had not
much news because i
i'm not even crazy about this segment we
could we could change this segment for
something else
yeah maybe we should you got any uh like
a toast we talked about doing a toast to
something anything impressing you or
or something you're proud of or i'll
come up with a toast next week let me
think of a toast now anything
i feel like i'm much better at uh i
might have to spin some pet peeves into
positives for my toast
right right people not inviting me to
that's the thing is like i'll say this
i'll toast a toast the one good thing
about this pandemic
i have not been invited to weddings oh
you hate a wedding
i just hate like i hate how annoyed
people get when we don't go
because it's like just look i'll go to
some but understand it's a big ask
that's all i'm saying
it's our job it's like we have to it's
like it's like literally the equivalent
of us being like take an entire take
monday through friday off work
oh yeah oh yeah and and get a plane
ticket
put on a suit sit through a [ __ ]
service
go to the reception where you don't know
anybody you know uncle dale and he's
weird you gotta you know get a headlock
from him so then you get really drunk
just to get through it
now you're hungover you gotta get back
on a plane i mean it's a nightmare
it's a lot i do do you ever do you do
you hate going to weddings too
i mean i don't hate them i have fun with
them i just i want to do stand-up
especially now
think about all the weddings that have
been backlogged oh
you're right it's going to be mayhem
dude
it's going to be and anytime i see a
friend of mine post a thing like we
decided to get married
at city hall ourselves because of the
pandemic i'm like [ __ ] yeah dude
hell yeah i'll send you a gift yeah
weddings are tough i mean i love
if it's a friend and you're like i'm
gonna know half the [ __ ]
party and i'm gonna see a band and get
drunk in a suit and
dance with my lady and all that yeah
sure it's good but
it always cuts into your all we have are
our weekends that's where i make my
money so yeah it's tough and i love
doing stand-ups so much
like that's the other thing and i miss
it so much like with the regularity we
used to be able to do it so
yeah no you're right like i love liz
wedding rachel's writing like i've had
i've been a wedding like this has been
the most fun but like
um yeah i want to do stand-up yeah yeah
no i'm with you i'm with you
like when i was in college that i wasn't
doing stand-up yet a wedding was awesome
it was like
oh free drinks and music and right you
know friends
but yeah now it's it's a chore then
especially when you're like this isn't
gonna last anyway
what the hell am i doing here i went to
one wedding and
it ended like two weeks after they got a
divorce immediately yeah i'm not gonna
say who you know the guy
damn oh yeah i do know him it sucked it
was kind of like
you tricked me damn
yeah i mean it still sucks to get
divorced of course of course yeah he's
doing great now and all that but it was
just this weird thing i think
the girl's parents made him do it which
is so stupid because now you just paid
for this
and it's over i mean i don't know
traditional [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] um yeah what how about uh
you wanna do a joke or a toast what are
you thinking i got a i got a bit here
it's in the rawest form and i need your
help on here please
i tried it on stage and it got something
but it was it was clunky as hell so i
think there's something there
all right i find it so interesting like
the bio
biology of humans like you can see a
girl
and she's you can see her like oh she's
got pretty hair and immediately you're
like i want to [ __ ] her
so it's kind of crazy that your body and
your mind
see this woman with pretty hair and you
automatically think i want to make a
baby with her
but your mind knows you're not going to
have a baby you're just going to
simulate having a baby you're just going
to do the the fun part you know
but your body thinks you're going to
actually do the baby thing that's why
you get a boner
you know so your your brain's going
let's go [ __ ] this chick or fake
[ __ ] and your dick doesn't know your
dick's like i'm in let's make that kid
but maybe that's why you can't get it up
sometimes because your brain and your
body are too in tune
so your your brain's like let's go [ __ ]
her why aren't you hard your dick's like
what am i an idiot i know what's
happening here
i know there's no baby i love it i think
there's something
there's a lot to unpack there's
something funny about the idea like
you throw a condom over your dick it's
like almost like uh like a mafioso
walking into a room thinking he's gonna
get made and he just like put a bag over
his head
right right this isn't what you thought
it was you know
yes that's that's the semen we're
killing the semen so
no baby will be made exactly yes
literally
you're not getting made
yes that's great that's a great angle
it's just so crazy because your dick has
no idea but your brain knows your
brain's like
i'm not gonna ever see this woman again
it's a one-night stand i'm in missouri
but your dick is like let's go here we
go
and if it does know it's kind of like
why would i get out of bed for this
yes it's such a big idea i love it i
think
something about having to trick your
penis is so funny like
yes he's really like
but i think you make a point that's why
the condom is so because it's hard to
get a boner with a condom maybe because
that your dick's kind of starting to
figure it out like wait a minute
why wouldn't you want a baby yeah i
thought that's what we're doing here
what the [ __ ]
yeah your dick thinks you're just gonna
knock someone up right right
your dick doesn't have any but you need
your brain because the dick doesn't ask
any questions
the dick isn't like hey you've only
known her for for 40 minutes
yeah the brain is you need the brain the
brain's protecting the entire body the
penis is just thinking about itself
ah yeah yeah that's true
all right yeah the dick is like it's
almost like
uh you know they say you're thinking
with your penis like no you're thinking
with your brain
because well hold on
yeah there's a lot here you're thinking
with your penis and you go
yeah but i'm controlling him right
it's almost like when your parents are
like
hey kids how are you and then you tell
your wife like
we gotta go to the uh d-o-c-t-o-r
and your kid's like what what what are
we doing like we're getting ice cream
you know how you have to you have to
spell it out for the wife and the kids
have no idea
yeah that's interesting and that maybe
maybe that's how you work in the can't
get it up
angle right i'm bringing kids in which
is odd but yeah
kids it's a tough sell
but you see what i'm saying you know
yeah i totally i totally get what you're
doing
um having a you kind of have to mislead
there's something very mafia about it to
me where you're like we're going uh
we're going to this place and then you
take them there and you're like this
isn't the
clack you know oh yeah right right
yeah cause pesci thought he was about to
get made and they shot him in the head
there's something about having to lie
and you're lying to yourself your penis
is a part of you
yes yes but your penis
doesn't realize it's power
like this thing penis you're just
thinking like yeah you were made
to you know what it is the penis was
made
to have babies that's the whole purpose
yeah but we've made some advancements
like
penis doesn't have eyes penis doesn't
know what's on the internet penis
doesn't know
where a lot of his [ __ ] ends up a lot of
the time
and thank god for that thank god for
that penis would look and be like
you're putting it where yeah this is
horrible i'm here to make what if penis
is just like a really sweet
i'm here to make babies right right why
does it smell like [ __ ] in here
why am i on her breast
even the mouth must be confusing to the
dick like why are there teeth in this
[ __ ]
this is getting pretty dirty but i think
it's an interesting idea
i like i like the i like to set up a lot
of um
and i'm a step slow i apologize i'm
hungover as [ __ ] but
i think the uh
don't don't push it don't no no no i i
think
finding a second use that's kind of what
the penis is yeah
yeah it's almost like when the phone got
a camera where you're like
no you can do other [ __ ] now we do right
right
okay okay that's not it that's not it
but the penis has a second use
second use i i like that
and it kind of hasn't caught up yet and
thank god it hasn't
with no oh man can you imagine you'd
have to
i mean that's what you're doing though
you have to drug the penis sometimes
yeah yeah pretty much like you have to
lie to it yeah you know definitely
having a baby
maybe it is
i mean you could maybe like you're
trying to sweet talk peanut come on
penis think about all the times i give
you massages
oh yeah yeah yeah i'm so good to you
venus
right right i don't know i'm getting too
dirty now
all right well what do you got you got
any ideas i had not i had an idea for a
bit
about uh this woman was trying to set me
up on a date and she was like so
what kind of woman do you like like give
me the type of woman that you want to be
set up with and i think
um it revealed to me like i watched too
much porn because i was like you know
mature
busty uh hand job uh
asian yeah that's funny
yeah it hit i did the other night a hand
job got a nice
something yeah yeah but sure oh that's
funny mature
neighbor uh step mom step mom
she's like wait what right right anthony
like what what
ebony
this is a quick one that's no that's
there's a lot there i think
yeah and you can keep going like yeah
you know uh
in a where do people [ __ ] like in a in a
what do you call those uh in a test home
you know like you're
a realtor you know
[Laughter]
stockings they're like what yeah yeah
that's interesting like because a woman
would never do that
a woman goes off a rom-com you know like
funny ambitious smart
charming and you're going off a porn
that's a good point yeah a woman is
going off
a type of dude like i feel like they're
going for
it's funny i feel like guys go for like
fake professions and women want real
professions
oh interesting yeah
even at a male strip club all the dudes
have jobs
right you know which has been done
before but they come out
with chairman cop whatever construction
worker
whereas a stripper just comes out as hot
a female stripper
that's true i feel like someone must
have done that angle though now
yeah yeah i'm sure i'm just i'm just
throwing up spitballing different
ideas but like it's i think i'm
comparing it to what a woman would say
because a woman's going off like a
romance novel or a rom-com
or some guy they actually already like
and you're handsome
handsome lawyer right uh handsome
successful
bigger bike i've never yeah i've never
been like she needs to have a big
apartment
yeah yeah yeah it's funny because
success has nothing to do with our
fantasy but with women it's like i'd
like a guy who's ambitious
you know makes money good job doctor
i feel like this must have been done
though this thing i don't know no
i don't think the poor thing i don't
think the porn thing has been done
that's funny that's very you too
i think that feels like a mural
um all right that porn joke from the the
old special was like
uh it like makes women sound better it's
so politically correct it's like
it's not a gum shot it's a facial oh
yeah yeah
that bit was huge but big beautiful
woman yeah you're not
cosmo's meaner to women than porn that
was a bit you're not you're not
fat and porn you're big
there's no fat and old uh cosmic but
there's fat no porn right again
right cosmo is like how to shed that
last ten pounds porn is like you're
perfect we have a category for you right
here
yeah you're not fat you're a big
beautiful woman you're not old you're
mature you're not covered in semen
you're getting a facial that's a great
bit and all half the fun of that bit
well not half the fun but a funny part
for me
is picturing you with your dick in your
hand about to jerk off going
oh i got something i gotta write this
down
isn't that funny do you ever do that
when you're like you know with may or
something you know you're just doing
your thing and then you're like
can you give me a second yeah oh yeah
that's the worst
i mean but you got to get that bit down
i also forget it
[ __ ] yeah gotta write it down we were
fooling around the other night and and i
was like oh let me turn the uh the
lights on
because she wears contacts and she
didn't have her contacts in
and she's like let me turn the light i
was like let me turn the lights on you
probably can't see me because you have
bad vision she was like no it's kind of
hot and i was like
ah geez you know it's hotter if you
can't see me so i was like i gotta write
this down and it totally ruined the mood
that's hilarious yeah i had uh during
quarantine uh
she gave me a haircut you know and she
goes wow you don't look like yourself
at all yeah and then she started kissing
me and i was like
why are you [ __ ] kissing after you
tell me that right
right exactly but you got to write it
down
got to write it down well people make
sure to keep emailing us at uh
we might be drunk pod at gmail we'll
read those on uh the patreon app
we got a lot of patreon people already
dude yeah
yeah send the stuff or read it you could
get your [ __ ] read on
on the on the live app on the patreon
and
some funny stuff some great premises a
lot of talented uh
drunks out there is that we're calling
our people
the drunks i like the drunks so the
booze bags or the booze hounds or the
the bar flies i don't want to leave out
people who are in recovery that's my
only fear because we do have a lot of we
have a lot of listeners to say they're
in recovery so i like that too so
we'll think of something though yeah
yeah that's true
addicts i mean alcoholic could go both
ways that's
alkies alkies
yes i like that that's good i like that
too the elkies all right till further
notice that's that's what we're going
with
all right perfect well good stuff
baby all right guys keep listening
subscribe to the patreon
uh give us a nice review on itunes and
uh keep on listening oh and follow the
instagram page we might be drunk
oh shout out to the email address
oh we might be drunk pod at gmail.com
there it is and we get we got so many
emails already so
we appreciate it we changed the email to
uh
you know to a new one but i think this
is this is the keeper we figured it out
finally yes here here all right
keep going on the patreon guys bye